ils sont mignons mais des vastes
certains milieux naturels et causent des
dommages en agriculture et cerfs de
virginie sont en surabondance dans le
sud du québec et plusieurs se demandent
aujourd'hui comment gérer leur
population on tient à vous en aviser
certaines images en début de reportages
pourrait choquer les routes du québec
traverse bien souvent village zones
agricoles forêts et ne sont pas toujours
sûr surtout en début de soirée où les
rencontres sont parfois imprévisibles
[Musique]
ce genre d'accident impliquant le cerf
de virginie a doublé depuis huit ans au
québec passant d'environ 4000 en 2012 à
plus de 8000 en 2020 c'est un pacte avec
des cervidés font près de 400 blessés
chaque année
[Musique]
on
plusieurs de ces collisions surviennent
dans les régions du sud du québec où les
serres abonde un peu partout
[Musique]
ici on les surprend sur une terre
agricole
là bas on les retrouve dans les cours
arrière de résidence durant l'hiver où
il se régale dans les aides cèdre
le cerf de virginie un cervidé de la
famille des chevreuils a une durée de
vie d'environ une dizaine d'années
la plupart des animaux qu'on a deux mais
ce ticket dans l'histoire de l'humanité
ce sont des ongulés donc c'est des
animaux qui en général sont tolérants la
présence humaine donc les moutons les
chèvres
les vaches on est toutes la même famille
des ongulés des ruminants comme un cerf
de juin le ministère de la faune évalue
aujourd'hui cette population à 250 mille
têtes au québec près de 325 me dit si on
inclut ceux de l'île d'anticosti
c'est le double de l'inventaire réalisé
il ya 30 ans même si leur nombre varie
beaucoup selon les secteurs
plus de la moitié des populations de
cerfs sont concentrées dans le sud du
québec
quand on est davantage dans des régions
sans du québec estrie montérégie
on est vraiment dans des populations à
bordeaux à certains endroits on peut
compter jusqu'à 37 ou kilomètres carrés
alors qu'une dose site est viable pour
l'habitat est estimé à environ 3,5 serre
ou kilomètres carrés quand qu'on arrive
au delà du sang salle comme ettore où
est-ce qu'on peut même arriver dans ces
régions là tout de 10,1 kilomètres
carrés là on commence à avoir des
dommages au niveau de l'habitat des
problèmes de cohabitation
donc là oui on peut parler vraiment de
population très abondants
cette vidéo amateur montre une
quarantaine de cerfs de virginie
traversant la route du port à nicolet
un rituel qu'il répète matin et soir
durant l'hiver tous ces serres ont élu
domicile sur les terres de jean leblanc
ce matin-là il rencontrait son
représentant de l'union des producteurs
agricoles droite non jusqu'au plus loin
il ya le troupeau d'environ 5 chevreuil
qui passe vers ici puis c'est dans les
chantiers au taux aussi bas ceci reste
des résidus de maïs y creuse puis manger
les feuilles toujours 8 même agriculteur
daniel labelle représente peut être cinq
mille producteurs agricoles les
acériculteurs du centre du québec
c'est le producteur qui nous
interpellent pour des dommages au cham
pertes de récoles piétinement sa cause
de dommages au niveau de la forêt au
niveau des installations acéricole puis
au niveau des champs aussi le cerf de
virginie est nourrie sur le bras des
agriculteurs à la rituelle ce type de
dommages
on retrouve un peu partout dans le sud
du québec comme ici dans cette salle
plénière de brownstone ouest en estrie
où les soeurs ont dévoré la base des
conifères
ailleurs dans la région il n'est plus
rare d'apercevoir des attroupements de
plusieurs dizaines de cervidés dans les
champs agricoles
mais comment expliquer cette
surabondance de cerfs de virginie au
québec alors qu'il n'y a pas si
longtemps
l'espèce était en détruit dans les
années 70 une décision qui était prise
puisque les populations étaient très
très faible et diminué donc eu ce qu'on
appelle la loi du monde donc en 1974 le
gouvernement du québec a décidé de taxer
la chasse porté sur le segment mort à
dieu en épargnant justement les cerfs
sans bois qui sont les femelles adultes
les jeunes de l'année les femmes à
partir de la fin des années 90 début des
années 2000
de plus en plus les populations ont
augmenté
un autre facteurs contribuent à cette
augmentation
les hivers ne sont plus ce qu'ils
étaient au sud du fleuve saint laurent
la neige et le froid ont longtemps été
des régulateurs naturel des populations
de cerfs de virginie un hiver plus rude
pouvait fauché le tiers d'une population
mais les temps ont changé au cours des
dernières années en estrie montérégie
sein du québec
il n'ya plus dur et rigoureux pour le
sol donc j'étais mortalité sont beaucoup
plus faible presque absent au niveau de
ces populations là les serbes sont donc
devenus très nombreux ce qui les force à
explorer de nouveaux garde manger des
choses d'approvisionnement qui les
rapproche de plus en plus des humains et
ce nouvel environnement les protègent de
leurs prédateurs naturels comme le loup
le coyote ou le lynx roux la présence
humaine faire en sorte que les
prédateurs sont moins présents moins
efficace ce qui vient ça morizet le cerf
de virginie directement un autre
prédateur est aussi moins présent
le chasseur depuis 2007 le québec a
perdu près de trente huit mille adeptes
de la chasse au cerf de virginie
en 2020 on en comptait 130 6413 donc on
n'a pas le choix de ramener la relève de
chasseurs à à cette pratique là au
niveau du loisir et du sport
par la suite on a aussi la limite de
prises par chasseur qui était
globalement d'un sa part chassa au
québec
maintenant il est de deux soeurs par
chanson en 2020 les chasseurs québécois
ont abattu plus de 48000 sert de ce
nombre on retrouve près de 5000 francs
29500 mal et seulement 13600 femelles
le groupe qui est responsable de
l'augmentation n'a pas placé ans
évidemment les femelles parce que c'est
elle qui produisent les jeunes lorsque
les ressources sont abondantes les
jeunes femelles à un ennemi vont se
reproduire et très rapidement 2 et nuit
on voit des jumeaux et triplés
si on veut réduire la population dans
les études qu'on a fait c'est vraiment
qu'il faut augmenter la mortalité des
femelles adultes
donc ça devrait permettre de réduire
survolé trou d'accroissement des
populations puis éventuellement de
stabiliser donc en 2020 on a aussi le
nombre de pnc en bois et même dans
d'autres périodes de chasse il est
possible de récolter cet enseignement là
pour justement mieux contrôler les
populations
mais pour châssis plus de femelles il
faut accéder à leur territoire
or le problème c'est que 86% des zones
de chasse au québec sont situées sur des
terres privées
le propriétaire d'un terrain peut
pointer de la chasse mais il peut
interdire l'accès au territoire où te
donner l'accès au territoire mais a un
nom tellement faible de personnes que
contrôle potentiel des cerfs de virginie
est plutôt faible
[Musique]
la surabondance des serres n'affecte pas
uniquement les zones rurales
un grand nombre d'entre eux se déplacent
vers des secteurs plus urbanisée de la
rive sud
grâce à des corridors naturels comme des
colts des boisés ou des terres agricoles
les airs peuvent avoir accès au parc de
longueuil et de saint-bruno puis à ceux
des îles de boucherville et l'est de
montréal
[Musique]
on commence à avoir des problèmes de
surpopulation ça diminue donc ça c'est
des problèmes de cohabitation
on doit passer à l'action avec les
intervenants du milieu les municipalités
ont aussi les responsables d assumer
[Musique]
pour diminuer les populations de cerfs
sur leur territoire certaines villes
comme sherbrooke ont eu recours à une
chasse contrôlé en n'autorisant que des
armes à moins de reporter comme l'arc et
l'arbalète
mais cette chasse là doit être modulé
pour assurer bien sûr la sécurité des
citoyens tout ça donc un parent peut
être fermé pendant quelques heures pour
récolter quelques bêtes et poussins si
cette solution là n'est pas possible il
faut regarder les autres options
possibles
quelles sont ces autres options pour les
cerfs en surnombre peut-on les
transporter et les relocaliser ailleurs
vers l'argent nature ailleurs c'est une
fausse solution saas et fire a été
mesuré une grande proportion des animaux
morts à l'intérieur dans l'année qui
suit donc les petits commerces est
questionnable
sinon peut-on stériliser les femelles et
si c'est possible
comment le faire
il ya une façon sympa chirurgicale
classique ou stérilisés puis un moyen
comme de vacciner pour les rendre ni
plus ni moins infertiles desailly ces
deux injections la difficulté c'est que
en effet encore tout à fait au point que
les contraceptifs faut quand même
probablement les capturer plus
l'injecter donc sa demande
l'immobilisation chimique des animaux
donc ça impose un stress
puis cette méthode ne l ai pas
permanente nécessairement pour mieux
contrôler la taille des populations de
cerfs dans les parcs urbains
plusieurs scientifiques recommandent la
capture avec euthanasie évidemment ça
serait mieux parce que là c'est fait par
des biologistes des professionnels qui
vont dans les parcs on minimise le plus
possible la souffrance puis il ya pas
trop de risque non plus pour les gens
qui viennent tôt donc ça c'est la
sociaux qui serait envisagée mais pour
plusieurs résidants l'abattage des
serres n'est pas une solution
malgré qu'on récolte en quarante et
cinquante mille cerf de virginie par la
chasse sportive au québec quand qu'on
arrive en milieu urbain interurbain on
est dans un autre contexte donc souvent
le cerf de virginie est très émotif au
niveau des citoyens citoyennes
dans ces milieux là bas les gens
connaissent pratiquement les cerfs de
virginie par leur nom fait que je
comprends que les actions létale très
difficile à accepter
les enfants adorent lui même faire ces
espèces sur des grands dieux qu'ils sont
beaux sont intéressants à regarder
je comprends tout à fait les gens
pourquoi il veut les protéger
par contre ça me manque ça continue
d'augmenter puis le les ennemis
deviennent en mauvaise condition un
certain moment où l'écosystème peut
complètement balance et puis on perd la
forêt qui l'a donc il faut prendre le
temps de bien comprendre le contexte des
ducs est un petit peu de caisse que est
vraiment le sens de virginie cette ligne
de population rapide
il est dommage que ça peut causer aux
écosystèmes et l'habitat le cerf cache
la forêt le cerf est une espèce
magnifique charismatique on aime tous il
le dommages à la forêt des rôles on vous
prive que pour lui très discret meslier
présent y est chronique comme un fou qui
voudraient tout le temps ça fait d'un
thème d'année que ccc brouter de façon
chronique vient elle aussi les espèces
envahissantes qu'un profil
le ministère veut bien sûr assurer la
pérennité des cheptels à l'ensemble du
territoire québécois et même au niveau
des municipalités mais un moment donné
il ya un certain contrôle faut assumer
pour bien gérer les populations s'en
sort qu'on avait vraiment des problèmes
sérieux des problèmes sérieux de santé
publique comme les risques de
transmission de la maladie de lyme par
meetic et les cerfs en transporte
beaucoup c'est que le chevreuil lui
permet aux tic des temps santé puis d'en
avoir en masse comme dans le parc de
longueuil et où je suis présentement
étant donné qu'on a une sous population
de chevreuils on a également une
surpopulation de tic au québec l'estrie
et la montérégie sont les secteurs les
plus touchés par la maladie de lyme
incidemment ces deux régions sont aussi
confrontés à une forte population de
cerfs de virginie a été démontrée en
nouvelle angleterre là dans certains
milieux où une diminution des
populations de cerfs et est associée à
une diminution des populations de tic et
une diminution des codes de maladie de
lyme dans la population humaine faut pas
oublier là que la situation actuelle
on ya contribué on est rentré dans
l'écosystème d'une façon peut-être plus
ou moins adéquat
puis l'on est en train d'en vivre les
conséquences
la question c est ce qu est ce que la
communauté veut faire avec ça
et pendant que les villes les
propriétaires terriens et le ministère
et cette s'entendre sur les actions à
prendre la croissance des populations de
cerfs se poursuit dans le sud du québec
les effets du cerf de virginie
deviennent plus importants et plus
rapide que les effets des changements
climatiques
ils ont la capacité de convertir des
écosystèmes encore plus rapidement que
le changement climatique le fait humain
[Musique]